les objets improbables des stars le 17
janvier dernier le prince philip époux
de la reine elizabeth ii était victime
des actions de voiture on le sait
heureusement sans gravité bas cette
semaine on a appris que des débris de
son véhicule notamment le le le comment
s'appelle le rétroviseur tout simplement
ont été mis aux enchères sur internet
c'est monté jusqu'à 76 mille euros c'est
aberrant donc on s'est posé la question
combien les fans sont prêts à débourser
pour acheter des objets insolites de
stargaard et des bouts de la voiture
accidentée du prince philip d'edimbourg
un petit malin prétend avoir ramassé des
morceaux de verre sur les lieux de
l'accident morceaux de verre qui l'a
immédiatement mise en ligne aux enchères
et oui vous avez bien entendu des mous
du phare de la voiture accidentée du
prince philippe le mari de la reine
elizabeth aux enchères 119 personnes ont
fait une offre
on en était à 65 milles 900 livres avant
que le site ne retire l'annoncent et la
liste des objets de stars que les fans
sont prêts à payer des fortunes est
inimaginable
swing mâché par britney spears qui n'en
veut adjugée à une fan pour quatorze
mille dollars négocié mais par johnny
ramassé sur le trottoir qui n'en veut à
juger un fan pour 250 euros de
félicitations
[Musique]
faisons bhl de lady gaga tombé lors d'un
concert et attendait aux états unis ça
fait même une émission un faux ongles le
retrouver sur scène alors votre au prix
ici une fois deux fois quatre à douze
mille dollars
les fans sont prêtes à tous c'est à dire
n'importe quoi pour s'offrir quelque
chose de leur idole fan de tom cruise
investissez dans l'eau chlorée de sa
piscine 135 $ et 50 centimes les 75
centilitres idéal pour baptiser un
enfant ou éloigner le mauvais oeil
précise le vendeur encore plus
surréaliste là c'est carrément de la
poésie de l'air capturés lors des
concerts de kanye west ou d'adèle et ça
se vend aussi alors la starmania
va-t-elle trop loin c'est quand même
hallucinant et j'ai fait que chaque
chroniqueur à un objet totalement
insolite qui a été vendu sébastien
j'imagine que ces 2 2 qui pendent quel
objet de totalement insolite a été
vendue deux stars sa gelée vécu en live
c'est un jour on était à malibu derrière
britney spears on était une petite
quinzaine à un moment elle a eu du mal à
à se dégager
on va rouler en voiture elle a roulé sur
le pied d'un photographe qui était en
tongs chaussettes
la grande classe et ça a laissé une
trace de pneus le jour même il a mis sur
ebay la chaussette avec la trace de pneu
et ça s'est vendu des milliers de
dollars mais qu'il a reversé à une
oeuvre
voilà lui sinon alors daniel qu'est ce
que vous avez peut-être mais là je me
rends à petite anecdote perso je
comprends quand même que ce phénomène
parce que j'étais amoureuse de mon prof
de maths et je ramassais les craies les
mégots qui l'avait touché jeu qu'ont
fait nos mails
raymond samara la mère de magali les
normands il ya quand même eu un slip
salle d'ennemis stress les vendus 7500
7600 euros par don c'est oui mais c'est
vrai la dentelle avec alerte et coquine
à elvis à messi et quelques années après
le téléphone a fait une chanson qui
s'intitule et ça se sent que c'est toi
donc s'il sait que si le site avait été
propre on l'aurait vendu moins cher
c'est bien évidemment ça n'a aucun
intérêt cet institut
voilà pour cette info la vraie question
c'est comment ces objets peuvent être
identifiées qui avait authentifié par
mons ac un marché des strokes ne s'est
pas c'est pas le dossier de la caisse
que vous avez oui un trucs délirants
dans les années 60 les beatles sont pas
contents du papier toilette qui a dans
l'est dans les studios d'abbey road et
keller sur des enregistrements il le
trouve un peu rêche et on revend il ya
quelques années soixante mille euros le
rouleau de papier toilette jamais
utilisé pour locaux contre à mon slip
d'elvis sinon quand même c'est pas en
revenant sur terre
c'était un triple épaisseur j'espère au
moins qu'on soit toujours l'utiliser
myriam alors vous savez là hélas la
mèche rebelle alors ça tout les fans
adorent et les couper et donc ils ont
mis en vente cette fameuse semaine c'est
monté jusqu'à 5,5 millions d'euros en
allemand c'est un petit plaisantin qui
avait fait monter les enchères et sûre
de ce chiffre oui je suis sûr de ce
chiffre et finalement la mèche a été
vendu 28 700 euros et ça a été donné à
une oeuvre de charleroi fou comme magali
alors moi c'est sûr le chanteur des one
direction
ah ah ah si j'ai bien dit ces oisillons
lexus vendues en poste à quoi un test à
tout
combien ou pas c'est pas
quatre vingt sept mille dollars en mai
ce blog est là des scoops ou pas voilà
luke adam voiture est plus sale parce
que c'était un mouchoir utiliser de sky
swenson alors fait est là elle s'est
mouché dedans en direct aux deux
dendaletche aux états unis elle s'est
bien couché dans à la fois du doigt un
petit plastique voilà et elle a vendu
pour 6000 dollars l'équivalent de est
alors égale elle a donné aux restos du
coeur locale a refusé
c'était pour faire une gamme assez qu'à
chaque fois c'est quand même bien dans
un malade aux abdos contexte catherine
c'est plutôt l'inversé les assistantes
de mariah carey après un concert ramasse
tous cas là mâchouille un chewing gum un
gobelet pour qu'il n'ait pas d'objets
avec son adn qu'ils puissent être
récupérés par les fans est mis aux
enchères
pourquoi la lentille ce qu'on met ces
objets aux enchères si vous trouvez un
objet de prétendument ait appartenu à
mariah carey ce n'est pas à elle
ils ont tout ramassé très bien rachel
bah moi c'est une petite histoire un peu
mignonne c'est james blunt qui avait mis
aux enchères donc sa soeur entre
guillemets en fait si elle devait se
rendre à des funérailles
elle ne pouvait pas donc il a proposé à
des gens de l'emmener et il ya un homme
qui la met gentiment et au final ils
sont ensemble ils ont des enfants mais
non alors moi on finit par quelque chose
de mignon et très mignon alors d'abord
on a un sondage
car voilà ils dépensent des sommes
folles pour hse de stars à ce que je
comprends je comprends pas je comprends
pas 80%